[موسيقى]
وانا بدور بحس ان انا
شايفه العالم اصفى
[موسيقى]
واجمل انا اسمي افنان شاهر عندي 29 سنه
خريجه لسان صح وجامعه عين شمس هناك في
المسرح بدات بطريقه يعني عظيمه جدا
بالنسبه لي وبايل قوي اتعلم الدوران او
المولويه انا بقيت راقصه مولويه عن طريق
الفن انا ممثله جال لنا المخرج في يوم قال
لنا هنعمل روايه قواعد العشق الاربعون
لاليت شفاق مؤلفه تركيه انا كنت قرات
الروايه قبليها وكنت معجبه بيه جدا ومعجبه
براكتر ورد الصحراء جدا اللي هي عاهره
عايزه تتوب هتوب على ايد ايدي شمس
التبريزي وهتبقى من اوائل الناس اللي
هتتعلم الدوران او رقصه سما زي ما كانوا
بيسموها ساعتها
[موسيقى]
احنا كل حاجه فينا بتدور وكل حاجه حوالينا
بتدور فالدور هو جزء لا يتجزا من الطبيعه
ومن
الكون دوران هو اصل كل شيء ف بتعرفي
تتواصلي مع نفسك كويس جدا بتفهميه اكتر
وبناء عليه بتشوفي حاجات كتير قوي حواليكي
بشكل مختلف
تماما وانا بدور قادره اشوف الحاجات
الحلوه اكتر قادره طول الوقت ان انا ابقى
اا فاهمه تغيرات وفاهمه انه ما فيش حاجه
ثابته وده شيء مريح جدا يعني انا الدوران
بالنسبه لي لو ه فسره بكلمه فهي هتبقى
رحله اتمنى ان انا لما اخلصها ابقى سبت
اثر طيب او حلو في اي حد
شافني اللبس كله كل تفصيله فيه ليها معنى
واضح اللبس لونه ابيض علشان هو بيرمز
للكفن انك قادره تدخلي دلوقتي تعملي عصف
جسدي كبير علشان جسمك يبقى مرهق جدا لدرجه
ان روحك هي اللي مسيطره على على كل شيء
الشيء اللي بيتلبس على الدماغ اسمه شاهد
القبر اللي هو الشيء اللي بيبقى موجود فوق
[موسيقى]
القبر بدات الحمد لله في الحلم اللي انا
كنت بحلمه من زمان قوي وهو تاسيس فريق
بنات اسمه دوري هو هيبدا من خلال مهرجان
سماع في شهر تس ان شاء الله وده
مهرجان صوفيه مشهور ومهم جدا في مصر وان
شاء الله يعني ابقى قادره ان الفرقه دي
تلف
العالم الرساله اللي انا عايزه اقدمها هو
انه حاولي طول الوقت تجربي كل حاجه تتعرفي
فيها على نفسك عشان لما تعرفي انت مين
هتبقي شخص مؤثر جدا جدا
جدا
الله